demain lyon sera à nice victime du
mauvais temps lyon n'a pas joué le
week-end dernier c'est donc la première
sortie des lyonnais après la trêve ce
club de lyon en 6e du classement avec un
match en moins par est très serein même
un peu discret
ce qui ne veut pas dire pour autant que
les troupes de chiesa et de jacquet ont
abandonné toute idée de conquérir le
titre
en réalité ils gardent toutes leurs
ambitions intactes
alors jean vidal est allé voir ce club
de lyon qui derrière les premiers du
classement se tient toujours à l'affût à
juste raison d'ailleurs
l'olympique lyonnais a surpris
agréablement ses supporters au cours de
la première phase du championnat cette
équipe qui n'avait évité la descente en
deuxième division que par miracle à 100
dernière occupe en effet une honorable
place de sixième et pourtant lyon pour
des raisons financières avait dû se
séparer de quelques vedettes notamment
sur l'avant-centre international bernard
lacombe départ à peine compensée par le
retour de chauveau la venue de valadier
et de carrier aimé jacquet l'entraîneur
nous explique les raisons de cette
résurrection
ils ont qu'à une pause et une position
qui a été prise
et puis des objectifs très précis la
part des dirigeants je pense que ça a
été assez courageux d'une part et puis
d'autre part il ne faut pas oublier que
il reste de la qualité des éléments de
qualité
à l'exemple de serge chiesa jean
françois jodar et jean gallice qui
encadrent magnifiquement ses jeunes
joueurs
et puis je dois dire que quatre joueurs
sont arrivés au club qui a priori venait
de divisions inférieures tels que jean
tigana et jean-marc valadier et le tout
grâce peut-être à une volonté et un
désir de se surpasser a permis à cette
équipe lyonnaise d'être très attrayante
il semble aussi que lyon ait trouvé en
aimé jacquet l'entraîneur qui lui
fallait cet ancien international de 37
ans connaît bien le football
professionnel puisqu'il a joué à
saint-etienne et à lyon sous 58 lyon a
réussi de belles performances de
notamment un succès 2 à 0 face à
l'éternel rival saint-etienne
aimé jacquet nous présente son équipe
est bien la défense avec le retour de
yves chauveau qui a été quand même très
appréciée et qui nous a permis de
retrouver une certaine sécurité
je crois que vous avez à droite alexis
yougoslave
jean françois jodar qui les libéraux
dominique marais où christophe de des
bouillons puisqu'il est blessé à
l'actuel son stoppeur et puis patrick
paillot jouaya gauche à la place geeks
avaient opéré nous ont perdu guise et
d'un étang et au milieu vous avez
gilbert carrier qui nous vient justement
de rouen jean tigana qui a nouveaux
joueurs aussi et serge chiesa donc un
milieu qui est quand même très technique
et très présent alors que kesa ce que
vous êtes un capitaine heureux je sais
pas si c'est un capitaine heureux jeu
un joueur et un père héros mais un
capitaine heureux
pourquoi pas l'équipe marche bien je
pense tout bas ventre
est-ce que vous êtes content de votre
équipe est ce que ça vous plaît comme ça
de diriger des jeunes car cette équipe
lyonnaise est vraiment très jeune un
genou en fin il reste quand même
quelques anciens dedans et
je pense que c'est une bonne chose de
renouveler un peu à peu l'équipe lyon ne
devrait pas connaître les mêmes
difficultés que la saison dernière
son attaque est en nette amélioration
comme en témoignent les 41 but réussis
en 24 rencontres est devant avec jean
gallice qui est quand même les noms
détonateur de cette attaque puisqu'il
atteindre une certaine expérience
il est encadré deux jeunes joueurs c'est
à dire
karim maroc et jean jacques valadié et
puis peut venir s'insérer dans cette
équipe
alain olio jean marc martinez dijonnais
tous des jeunes joueurs qui ont déjà et
daniel de rêve qui est à l'armée qui ne
s'est pas entraîné ce matin qu'ils
peuvent très très facilement pas lié à
une défaillance
lyon a misé sur la carte jeunesse
dominique marais à 23 ans jean marc
martinez 22 car ils maroc 20 alain olio
21 jean tigana 23 et jean-marc valadier
un grand espoir n'a que 21 ans jean-marc
valadier vous êtes du midi vous êtes de
montpellier est ce que le climat lione
vous réussit lima sais pas enfin on s'y
habitue se passe trop important
au début j'étais un peu un peu privé de
soleil même femme et à ça je me suis
bien vite y ait eu cet entraînement d'un
professionnel caméras aux intérêts des
professionnels c'est pas trop dur pour
un jeune au départ au départ mais à la
longue le corps s'habitue aux efforts et
matériels pas de problème est quelle est
votre ambition en tant que jeune
footballeur devenir international bien
sûr professionnels d un premier temps
parce que je suis stagiaire et puis
après
l'avenir nous le dira et gagner la coupe
de france le championnat le plus loin
possible en coupe de france le
championnat jeu principal et disputer un
jour la coupe du monde sans doute assuré
du maintien l'olympique lyonnais fonde
de grands espoirs sur la coupe de france
et coupe que l'ol a gagné trois fois une
épreuve qui intéresse davantage de
public lyonnais que le championnat
je crois que ce qui symbolise un petit
peu l'ambiance yonnaise c'est cette
coupe de france moi je le regrette parce
que je pense que le championnat situe
bien mieux la valeur d'une équipe enfin
l élément est déterminant pour lyon
c'est la coupe de france je dois vous
dire que nous rencontrons équipe de
cannes qui est qu'alain difficile
malheureux et c'est pas sans inquiétude
que nous allons aborder ce match mais
nous avons des arguments
et puis de parts
le début de saison réalisé deux passes
et l'équipe je crois que et nous
espérons surtout aller le plus loin
possible en coupe de france mais aussi
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'il ya une
constance dans les résultats aidant les
prestations parce que c'est très
important
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que public
lyonnais est assez bout-dehors est assez
spéciale et nous essayons de la tirer le
plus possible en étant donné un bon
spectacle et en essayant de faire du bon
football
le président guy zerbib s'est fort
d'instaurer une nouvelle politique des
salaires les rémunérations fixes des
jeux ont été réduites mais les primes de
victoire augmenté
un système qui réussi aux lyonnais on
parle beaucoup de la politique que nous
sommes en train de mener lyon finalement
pour nous la limite c'est très simple
nous n'avons pas le choix nous n'avions
pas le choix en fin de saison passée
nous avions un déficit qui s'élevait qui
s'élèvent d'ailleurs malheureusement
toujours à un peu plus de 5 millions
vous savez dans ces cas-là n'y a pas
d'alternative la démagogie ne peut pas
durer éternellement il nous fallait
prendre des dispositions radicales nous
les avons pris pour certains avec regret
mais ils n'ont nous n'avions pas le
choix comme vous disais donc à la limite
haute politique se trouve être facilitée
nous ne pouvons dans l'état actuel des
choses ne dépensait que ce que nous
avons en ressources au stade
point final alors c'est une politique
que nous continuerons et que mon ami le
président roger michaud a mené pour
redresser la situation financière du
club
ça c'est absolument sinéquanone nous ne
ferons pas autre chose tant que la
situation financière ne sera pas
redressée
[Musique]
ans